alle cose brutte
mattarella vieni qua voglio devo entrare
carlo quella più di ragazzi mi avete
visto nuovo video sono vari j oggi siamo
su world max io con sasha c'è anche la
freccetta sullo schermo che ci di dove
sei
eh sì è la modalità team sta roba qua
viventi ci troviamo subito presente ti
vedo anche quando vai fuori dallo stesso
di quando moriamo rinasciamo vicini di
essa scienza spa
l'unica roba che tra l'atro vedo di
diverso e che poi anche fermarti però
quello lo raggiungi solo quando fai un
tot di punti tv stop mi sa che poi
guarda pt fermo no aveva funzionato sono
fermo ma sta dimentica perché ci fece
due salsicce che si rimane meglio di lui
armi successivi tutto scemo solo tutto
scena ed è bravo cristo i familiari
arkema che botto fortissimo ti ha dato
entrato nel cura uscito qui sono qua
sotto aspetta aiutami mangiare la tua
kakà almeno neanche abitato un altro
scelgo sempre sasha per accompagnarmi
questi do perché almeno lui fa qualcosa
perché non faccio niente sono scarso ma
morte o le miglia mangiatevi mangia
trippa mangiato il papa sarà bene che tu
stai crescendo mi fa piacere io pian
piano cresce hai preso il mail in esatto
è bravo novell offre della feccia vera
tua parapendio a prendere altri voglio
nutrire come ma la mamma piccione grande
è morto lo gigante sono diventato grosso
cerca il pene grosso adesso dai 75 di un
buono arriva arriva arrivo tutto forte
ero diventato grosso sono un po sono un
[ __ ] porca italia dalle palle player
questo guardo io decido io questo rosso
si è questo qua è cattivo nel mio
comunque lo ammazzo io
brutto stop torta che taccia
bisogna farsi valere in questo modo che
si chiama nutella ma dove lo voglio solo
questo grosso di sotto hayama ucciso
nutella niente ragazzi sono scarso come
la morte
tu non muori da una vita e io voglio di
continuo seguiamo insieme papa fammi
vedere come si gioca ora c'è una cosa
che ho trovato grazie un buon regalo
sono grossi e raddoppiata fa la madonna
cos'è sta roba
questo non ci aiuta basta morire perché
moria di continuo che palle bravo
cosa ha ucciso ha inciso la bestia forte
basta ero disegnato a questo era per
quello che morire sempre sabato mai
fatto prendere cinque posizioni con
grande attesa è stato utile alla patria
grosso rende carlo adesso ti diamo il
permesso di soggiorno siepa che vi è chi
chiudo punti bravo ha chiuso le regioni
che è bravissimo va bene a me non
importa io mi ammazzo questo è arena e
arena sele arena e arena o diventano a o
sud il dato negativo che ha come così
non ce l'hanno più con me adesso
ok trovato la l'uscita più fatto punto
ma secondo te se io no ma io posso
passare anche attraverso no no va bene
un consono a grazie grazie sei molto
gentile quasi quasi preferisco non
puzzare però adesso non c'è più gente
attorno che mi scarsa le palle chissà
perché perché i miei puntino mai contro
un cazzo
ma le cose brutte e radio cazzo
[Musica]
il presidente da morto definitivamente
sasha non c'è cosa è successo 6 successo
ecco prendiamocela con lindo se troppo
pulito per me mastrolindo è morto è
morto per la stiamo col rosso dobbiamo
assolutamente fare la gang la scienza
deve dominare quindi nel mondo ammazzare
tutti quelli che incontra ma vogliamo
fare brutto in due il rapper di veristi
ampio restiamo sto qua giallo su di
giallo ti ammazzo la famiglia e poi
giallo su quello bianco su quello giallo
su quello bianco più di ammazzarti non
mi stanco attenta attenta attenta
attento a tempo attento attendevano i
curi vadono doppia doppia sono tutto
forte e viva l'africa brano finestra
scaglia prendi tu vedi tu vedi tu grazie
a te magari attento ai morenti
schiantarsi di me
no no 2 starbird sono scemo shop in shop
te l'ho detto che ci dice che ci
sbagliavamo perché erano tutti e due e
stato zitto perché non sapevo come la
sta riprendendo sta così si gira a
sinistra per caso muore ma tu lo hai
arato tutto questo mi ha [ __ ] i punti
voi maledetto blu arrivati blu perché io
sono storto van ness qua è quello che
hanno fatto i punti [ __ ] figlio
della merda ucciso perché mi rinnova la
morte si merita perché non cercando di
prendere qualche punto ma porca eva
lercia è questo voleva ed è sbattuto di
spago deciso no deciso bravo e lauren di
prendi tutti tu hai fra il figlio mio
cresce bene
da dove passato questo scemo
ecco la figlia che da casa ha detto
arrivato pesce mi sono eva e chiuse
chiuse chiuso che ho usato lei ha usato
lei perché il calcio è questo
scooby doo ha ucciso aveva tutti i punti
di merda però peccato non lo prende
renault a prendere che sotto i punti che
ti diminuiscono ok madonna come mi sono
il prossimo primo stato la emi sono
salvati simo per mamma mia con i suns
che culo
no chiuso solo far ciò che c'è fuori
morto morto a grande portiere vabbè che
disastro abbiamo fatto sia primi dopo
questo primo attentato maniera papa
collo mi sento in colpissi ma cazzo mi
voglio più stare tranquilla bene lei
presi tu sono contento dai ti seguo
finché non muori sono scappato del cicap
[ __ ] va bene va bene così prima
che distruggiamo la vita va bene così
sono contento di aver partecipato con te
papa che rick ross grazie papà figlio
perché sei stato anche mio padre oltre
che mi sbagli padri e figli tutti e due
molto grossi molto piccoli ma
l'importante è averlo sempre allungare
bravissimo esatto giocate a world max
per vedere se è riuscita a fare meglio
di noi che sarà così però l'altro c'è
anche la versione mobile di sto gioco
quindi a prossima volta ci giochiamo
mentre nadal telefoni va beh allora
baffo smetto siamo in vacanza ci
giochiamo lo stesso che siamo fortissimi
ci alleniamo durante i viaggi comunque
io ragazzi spero che questo video vi sia
piaciuto ringrazio bonsai sciopero e
partecipata erano fratello tisma e
questo mi è piaciuto come si è visto il
momento è un mi piace passate anche la
cai di sasha che vi trovate sempre
televisi schede ci vediamo se un docente
di comando per concludere 14 tricorno 3
va bè metti nei quattro è lo prendo
anche l'auto bollo aspetta e la campagna
aspetta anche la campanella chiudo con
giusto e se dovessi fischiateci vediamo
ha proseguito ragazzi